All right, so we used a workflow, to, you know, automate these manual tasks,
tell people what's going on automatically. What's
next? What, what should we build next?
>> So, in our flow, we have handled, sort of, the maintenance side of things.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But, what about the scheduling stuff? I mean,
we kind of built that out, but then, let it be.
>> Yeah, so scheduling, I imagine would look something like, I dunno,
whoever's doing the scheduling for the band says, hey, I
really like this band, let's schedule. Book him on the stage.
>> Right.
>> And then the stage manager probably gets
all upset because they're like hey, you didn't
tell me. Or, you know, the concert, the
festival promoter's like, woah, woah, woah, what's going on?
>> You three's already playing at that time. You can't have that time.
>> Yeah, yeah, I can't do that. Okay, so we need some way to
get these people talking to each other.
Making sure that nobody's doing anything crazy.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> So I imagine that would be the stage manager handling all that.
>> So,
similar to how we could assign tasks and things like that
to a maintenance worker, we can do that to a stage manager.
>> Sounds reasonable.
>> And we could do that, like what we're talking about
right now. You know, approving these, book bands at certain set times.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Using something really similar to
a workflow roll, called an approval process.
>> Okay, so this is the
[SOUND]
something you see with the stamp of approval before it can move on.
>> Right, I mean, it's just like a workflow
in the sense that you have automated actions, but
it involves that stamp of approval and that personal
interaction in order for it to complete the cycle.
>> Makes sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.